hi my name is jane e
and today i'm here to present my thesis
artistic vision
providing contextual guidance for
capture time decisions
so as cameras become more pervasive
people are interested in becoming better
photographers
however currently cameras provide
limited aid in improving artistic
aspects of a user's photograph
for a novice who's interested in
photography but has limited training
the prospects of taking a good photo can
be somewhat daunting
there are many photography resources
that can help
however it can be difficult to take the
abstract concepts taught by books for
instance
and apply them to your own work so in
education literature
this is referred to as transfer so it
can be challenging to bridge the gap
when transferring knowledge you've
learned in one context to a completely
new context
in-person art practice classes on the
other hand focus heavily on in-class
critiques
or crits so when a portion of these and
while a portion of these in-person
classes
will be about reading the literature and
understanding existing art
much of it will be about getting out and
practicing and then most importantly
having these in class crits
these scripts are super helpful for
getting feedback on how to directly
apply techniques you've learned in
readings
to your own work therefore closing the
knowledge transfer gap
but here you can see how visualizing
some abstract compositional ideas
can make them feel more concrete and
actionable
inspired by these in class critique
sessions we believe that the camera
viewport is prime real estate for
providing photographers
with artistic feedback in this way we
want to
further close this feedback loop so
photographers can use this information
in the moment
as they explore the scene and make
decisions about their photos
in particular we're inspired by the fact
that experts have trained their eyes to
see in a certain way
so as i look at an image they know how
to scan the scene to make sure they're
aware of different potential
ideas or mistakes and as a result
they can be very intentional about their
different artistic choices
despite the wide range of options
presented in front of them
novelists on the other hand might not
know where to put their attention
or what to consider when framing a photo
so we wondered
if we could help novices see in these
different ways as well
if they might be able to have access to
the range of artistic choices that
experts have available to them
and so this idea is what inspired my
thesis title artistic vision
therefore in my thesis we design capture
time interfaces to visualize key
artistic concepts with the goal of
helping novices develop this artistic
vision
so for novices personal creativity and
satisfaction is most important
therefore we care about promoting
creativity and improving self-assessed
photo quality
so throughout this talk when i refer to
novices i don't assume any level of
experience but i do assume the mindset
of having
interest in working towards developing
expertise
so my thesis i demonstrate this idea
through
three camera interfaces that focus on
three different photographic concepts
lighting composition
and finally declutter so specifically in
my work
i contribute new camera guidance
interfaces implemented as prototype
capture time tools
for each tool i design novice
interpretable visual overlays
to represent the considerations for a
key artistic concept
and realize them through real-time
algorithms for generating these
visualizations
before i get into the details of each
interface i want to talk through some of
our formative studies that informed the
design of those interfaces
we conducted a survey with 127
participants with an interest in
photography
and asked them what types of feedback
might help them in camera
we then did nine in-depth interviews
with experienced photographers
about their current practices and tools
many survey participants expressed that
they appreciated the individualized and
immediate feedback of in-person classes
or even going on a photo walk with more
experienced friends
so this enables reviewing and adjusting
while still in the context of their
current photo
both survey participants and experts
were interested in new ideas
especially suggestions for larger
changes as they preferred
to only make smaller framing adjustments
while editing
finally bose also expressed concern that
the interface might be too distracting
and destructive survey participants were
concerned that it would slow down their
photographic process
this was especially important in
situations with time pressure
such as when capturing a fleeting moment
or when traveling with a group
meanwhile experts emphasize the need to
maintain creative freedom
nonetheless around 90 of survey
participants were willing to spend an
extra couple of seconds
if not minutes on capture time guidance
in order to get a higher quality result
many experts also described consistently
using a number of overlays on their
camera
from leveling assistance to light
metering etc and not feeling like these
limited their creative flexibility
we take inspiration from these existing
overlays to design our interfaces
thus these became our three design goals
we want to design guidance that is
context aware and able to adapt to the
current scene
the guidance should support exploration
by helping photographers discover new
ideas
and finally the guidance should not
hinder the creative freedom or
flexibility of the photographer
so now i'll review some related work in
the context of these goals
i'll also refer back to them as i
describe our own design decisions later
on
recent developments in graphics and
vision have been quite helpful in
producing aesthetically improved images
these examples here include
automatically cropping a photo removing
distractors
or transferring lighting styles however
much of the related work in this area
focuses on automated workflows which can
somewhat detach users from the creative
experience of taking a photo
we can see that each of these is indeed
context aware
in fact a lot of work is put into trying
to recover the context in the image
they also do allow users to quickly
explore a wide range of options for
their image
however the options are still limited by
the already fixed content
of the image additionally some guided
photography interfaces do exist such as
those
shown here so these tools guide you to a
specific better option
on the left to a specific composition
and on the right
to achieve what what it defines as a
good selfie
these tools have an internal model of
aesthetics but they're mostly hidden
from the user and apply this model
without providing much explanation by
imposing a specific suggestion from the
tool
they limit exploration and creative
flexibility
since in our formative studies experts
mentioned using a variety of existing
and camera tools
we also took a closer look at what made
these tools useful
the light meter for example attempts to
evaluate if the current image is
properly exposed
the photographer uses this information
to adjust the camera to achieve better
overall lighting
however also note that a photographer
can choose to intentionally over or
under expose the image based on this
feedback
so i personally tend to like to capture
images of images a little darker than is
suggested by the light meter
we take inspiration from these existing
tools to design our guidance interfaces
so even with just the information from
the light meter there are infinite
parameters that you could change
to address this feedback
let's walk through some of the decisions
a photographer might be making
while taking this portrait the
photographer notices that the lighting
is very dark on her subject's face
she doesn't mind a few lighting styles
that she likes to use
guides are subject to orient
to achieve the one that she likes
next she composes a subject relative to
the objects in the background
so the image is currently centered and
she places a subject at the top
left thirds but there is a bright orange
bag in the photo instead
she adjusts the composition to place the
subject at the top right thirds
to remove the distracting clutter from
the background
and takes the photo
going back to the lighting i'll now walk
you through
each of the interfaces that we've
designed to assist with this process
so the photo starts out very backlit
rotating the subject in place
the photographer is able to achieve this
style called loop
which i will describe shortly
so for portrait lighting the important
context is the lighting in the
environment
to encourage exploration we want to make
sure users are aware of the lighting
style options in the context of their
current environment
and that they have flexibility to choose
between these different options
here the lighting style is called loop
it's characterized by the strong
light on the right side of the face and
the triangle
on the left cheek
so to create this look the photographer
carefully set up the studio as shown in
the top down diagram to the left
the light source is precisely angled to
the right side and slightly above the
face
to form the desired key triangle
so here's a more dramatic look called
badger characterized by the shadow along
the center line of the face
it requires two lights placed slightly
behind the face
portrait photographers have designed
many such portrait lighting setups
here's a poster showing a number of them
however most novices
don't know about these different
lighting options or how to create them
consider taking a portrait in an actual
environment like this one can we still
achieve these studio-like lighting
styles without studio lights
in many such cases you can achieve a
wide range of looks
just by having the subject rotate to
different angles in place
for these situations we built a
prototype interactive capture time tool
that would guide photographers through
the steps of exploring and choosing a
lighting style
and reorienting their subject to achieve
their desired style
now let's say we're using this tool to
take this portrait
our approach consists of these three
steps
first the photographer has to capture
the environment map
so we use a 360 camera to capture the
environment
in the next step we allow the user to
choose a lighting style from a gallery
of pre-designed options based on studio
portrait setups
so taking inspiration from the earlier
poster we recreated a number of those
lighting styles using virtual setups
and then taking in the context of the
current environment the tool calculates
the optimal angles for each lighting
style
and previews these best matches to the
user it's also able to determine some
styles that it finds
to be currently unattainable these are
displayed to the user in grey
now let's say we pick butterfly a
relatively evenly lit lighting style
this takes us the next step
where the tool will now guide us to
properly reorient in the scene
in order to best capture the butterfly
target
so following the guidance on the
interface
the photographer guides the subject to
turn a little less than 90 degrees
clockwise
once we're at the right orientation
we take the photo giving us the even
lighting of the butterfly style
thinking about our design goals the
first is that the feedback should be
context aware
so in this case we captured the most
important context the lighting in the
environment
by presenting the user with these many
options at once they can easily scan the
gallery to preview what the end result
might look like
the user has flexibility to choose
between these styles i won't go into the
details into the top in the talk but
for additional flexibility we also allow
customization of
target lighting styles
so how do we compute these orientations
here our current lighting is estimated
by render b
in order to compute an optimal angle we
need to be able to determine how close
the current lighting is
to the target lighting style we want to
achieve which here is loop
looking at lighting similarity the key
is relative regions of light and dark
thus for a given studio lighting style
we need to transform it into a
representation of its light and dark
regions
we generate this weighting function f of
x where for each pixel
x a positive value or orange means that
you want more light
and a negative value or blue means you
want less light
so once we have this orange and blue
waiting function
we use it to generate a score indicating
how similar the current lighting is
to this target style and that we call
our quality metric
and then here is the environment map l
corresponding to the render
b
we've walked through how to compute the
quality for a given environment
so at this orientation the quality
metric is
289 for this specific target studio
lighting
we can rotate the environment map to
compute a new quality value
notice that this rotation of the
environment map is equivalent to
rotating the subject
for this target and environment 23
degrees is the optimal orientation
here our quality metric is maximized
with a value of 332.
for this scene we also have the
corresponding photos at these angles
and so as we scrub through other
rotations notice how the light changes
at the lowest values the light is on the
other side of the face
looking more carefully at this loop
result you can see
the characteristic key triangle both on
the face and the renders on the right
and here we show another result for the
loop lighting style this demonstrates
the ability of our tool to handle
nighttime scenes
now let's look at another studio
lighting style left to rim
with a strong contour on the left side
of the face
so in this photo notice the desired
highlight
on the contour of the face
characteristic of rim lighting
we're also able to capture the rim along
this subject's face in an indoor scene
we ran a user study with 28 participants
to evaluate the usefulness of our tool
and the quality of the resulting photos
we asked participants to capture three
well-lit portraits
first using no tool then using a static
reference image
and showing the studio showing the
studio lighting styles and then manually
reorienting
and then finally using our tool
they found our tool significantly more
useful than the other two methods and
generated better lit portraits
participants liked that they were able
to capture different lighting styles
i was more intentional about lighting
and the environment my subject was
in i only really knew about one lighting
style before this
i really liked that it gave me an
assortment of different lighting
options and told me which were possible
in the given environment
i never realized how many there were to
choose from
another participant said i liked that it
made me think beyond just the content of
the photo
and also pay attention to where the
light sources are it
makes me feel like i can take much more
dramatic and varied photos in a limited
space
by representing portrait lighting as a
discrete set of lighting styles
and corresponding reorientation angles
we were able to allow participants
to consider varied lighting styles in
the context of the current scene
using the tool participants were able to
explore through a gallery of lighting
styles
pick their desired style and ultimately
achieve results that they believed were
a better quality
next we'll move on to composition to
review
here the photographer makes just a
slight adjustment to go from
a centered portrait to one where the
subject is at the top left thirds
so for composition the context we want
to consider is the relative positioning
of objects within the frame
exploring composition can involve moving
around
the camera to try to try out different
angles and framing
as well as moving the objects in frame
users should have creative flexibility
in choosing whatever compositions they
find appealing
one common way of describing composition
is using composition grids
like the rule of thirds the rule of
thirds
suggests that it can often be better to
place the subject around the thirds
lines
rather than centered like the door in
this image
so here's another image with the rule of
thirds grid overlaid
for these images these are the more
relevant lines as they align with
important objects or boundaries in the
images
however the rule of thirds is rather
restrictive and can only describe
a small set of compositional elements
notice in these images there are
many other strong lines that aren't
being described by the rule of thirds
in addition to thirds there are other
proportions that are known to be
visually pleasing
so the harmonic armature is a
composition grid that encompasses a
variety of these proportions
just like such as halves and quarters
formed by these intersecting diagonals
this can describe a wider range of
compositions
i would probably pick these as the most
relevant lines for describing these
compositions
but as you can see many lines are
reasonable it can be overwhelming to
find these alignments and interpret
composition with these more complex
grids
here are some images annotated by
professional photographers to explain
composition in blog posts and books
photographers will walk through
different aspects of a photo
highlighting the relevant subsets of
lines as they go
so this helps focus the attention of the
readers
we wanted to automate this process and
show these highlighted lines as overlays
directly in the camera
but first we wanted to understand if
such a tool would be useful for novices
and if so how to best design it
specifically there are many ways to
represent composition
we wondered if highlighting lines in a
composition grid like the harmonic
armature
was a helpful representation for users
to interpret composition
and if so how to decide what lines
aren't most relevant to highlight
to answer this we ran a mechanical turk
study where we had workers annotate
10 images per task after some basic
training on what composition is
they were asked to select one to four
lines from the harmonic armature that
best describe the composition of the
physical elements in the image
so here are some worker annotations
from these annotations we pitch the most
commonly annotated lines
as ground truth so here are
two other ground truth annotations
notice that workers are selecting lines
that intersect with salient regions
or regions of strong visual attention
so in the left image lines intersect
with the water droplet
in the middle with the animal's eye and
on the right along the boundaries of the
landscape
we also actually got feedback from the
workers expressing that they found the
task to be fun
so we've learned that novices do indeed
find the task of annotating photo
composition
by highlighting lines in a composite
grid composition grid
to be useful and approachable um they
were also relatively consistent in their
annotations
and highlighted lines through areas of
visual saliency
thus we wanted to design an algorithm
that would adaptively select the most
visually salient lines of the harmonic
armature
in order to do so we needed to give each
line a score
based on its proximity to visually
salient regions in the image
we started by computing a per pixel
saliency map
for each line the 14 lines in the
armature we generate a gaussian mask
along the line and multiply each one by
the saliency map
summing up the per pixel product gives
us a score for each line
we denote the lines with the top three
scores as our adaptive armature
for each of these lines here is a
previously shown ground truth mechanical
turk annotation
compared to our saliency based adaptive
armature
notice that the ground truth often has
two selected lines
we chose to highlight three in order to
provide more ideas to the user as they
use the tool
so here's our capture time tool it
overlays these relevant lines or
adaptive armatures
on the camera viewfinder here the
saliency algorithm is detecting that the
green object on the bench
is salient and the selecting lines that
intersect it
intersect with it to represent the
current composition
looking back at our design goals here we
are using saliency to capture the
relevant context
of the image by showing grid lines
we hope that users could more easily
think about possible composition options
and and that the highlights especially
might help them understand their current
composition or consider new composition
options
while still attending to other aspects
of the photo
finally the highlights are meant to
represent the current composition
choices
rather than impose a new composition so
users can choose to intentionally align
or misalign with the grid
but we chose the harmonic armature as
the underlying grid to just be able to
support
alignment to a wider range of
compositions
we ran a study with 24 participants to
understand if the tool
would help users capture photos that
they believed were more well composed
and if users felt creative while using
the tool
users experienced two different
conditions of the tool
one with a static composition grid
and a second dynamically highlighting
our adaptive armatures
participants completed six photo tasks
three at each of two locations
so the tasks were designed to increase
in scale and complexity
and to correspond and style across the
two locations
we counterbalanced location and
condition to avoid biases due to
location preferences
or learning effects
in both static and adaptive conditions
we saw participants
snapping elements in the image to lines
or points on the composition grid
for example this participant places the
subject the photo at these
different intersection points notice how
she jumps from one
intersection point to the next
here the participant aligns the edges of
the building to various vertical lines
on the grid
along the center and now the thirds
and the other thirds line and notice how
he pauses at the lines to refine each
alignment and examine the composition
here are a couple photos that
participants captured using the static
guidance
and here are a few captured using the
adaptive guidance
notice the range of compositions and
camera angles
so looking back at our user study
results we found that participants
indeed believed the photos that they
captured with the adaptive guidance were
better composed
in terms of the creative process we
heard a lot of
qualitative support suggesting that
users felt like the tool encouraged them
to explore new creative ideas and made
them feel confident in their ability to
compose photos
so let's watch some participants from
the summative study in action framing
their shots
here we see how seeing these different
highlighted lines gave participants new
ideas to
explore i want this the side of the
bench to align with the diagonal that
was highlighted
she goes on to say that she actually
didn't see it fit into this corner until
the line on the screen
showed up
the highlighting also provided
confirmation to the participants making
them more confident in their photos
okay i see the lines that i want
lighting up
so this looks good oh yeah it's really
nice because the lines like go through
the bulbasaur
with respect to our design goals we aim
to reflect the composition of the
current camera angle image
with the highlights in the grid so these
high-level grid representations
made it easier to explore the space of
possible compositions
and also highlighted new composition
ideas for participants to try
users have flexibility in how they
respond they can choose to
better align to these highlighted lines
align with different lines or
intentionally misalign elements relative
to the grid
finally we'll address decluttering the
image
so upon noticing the bright orange bag
the photographer adjusted the comp
adjusts the composition of the image
in order to remove this from the
background
placing the subject now at the top right
thirds of the image to achieve
the final portrait
for decluttering the important context
to consider
is what will draw the viewer's attention
exploring how to declutter an image
involves considering
how elements of the image contribute to
the overall story and what might focus
or distract
in particular it might involve trying
out different backgrounds that
better highlight the focal subject or
removing objects that take attention
away from the focal subject
users should have flexibility to decide
how they want to present
the story
it can be incredibly frustrating if you
take a photo only to realize
after the fact that there is some
unwanted clutter in the background
that distracts from the main focus of
the image
notice here in the left image the
subject blends into pat
into the pattern behind it and in the
right image
there are unwanted objects along the
left border
reframing to clarify the subject and
remove these instructors
really helps improve these images and
better directs the viewers
eyes so our eyes are drawn to regions of
high contrast
so light and dark dark on light
thus contrast around the subject will
clarify and declutter the overall image
called subject background separation
whereas
contrast in other regions especially the
border of the image will distract
causing the eyes to be
attracted away from the focal subject
called image border flicker
photographers recommend a number of
methods to be able to more easily see
the contrast in an image
for example they recommend squinting at
the image to see a blurred and higher
contrast version of the image
or looking at the image in grayscale to
focus on contrast without aspects of
color
on the right the photographer draws a
line around the subject
areas where contrast maybe is too low
between the subject and background are
shown as gaps
so looking back at our earlier examples
here are the images with subjects
outlined
in this way so you may notice from the
right image
that this outlining method doesn't
really do anything to highlight image
border flicker
inspired by this idea of using outlines
to highlight contrast and lack of
contrast
we hope to recreate this outlining as an
overlay directly in the camera
also extending it to contrast along the
image borders
so given an image our tool detects edges
throughout the image however we want to
be able to focus on edges related to
the subject background separation and
the image border flicker
in particular we need to identify a
border around the subject
so we realized we could estimate the
image subjects using object-based
saliency maps
these are different from those that we
used for the composition as they try to
identify entire objects rather just
rather than just
general regions of visual attention so
given this saliency map we segment the
image into regions describing
the subject the subject border the image
border
and the remaining background these
segmentations are then used
to classify and color code the edges
yellow designates edges within and
around the subject
cyan for edges around the image border
and white for the remaining background
edges we merge these
to form two edge-based overlays one
showing all
edges color coded at the top right and
the other
only showing the relevant edges around
the subject and image borders at the
bottom
so here's the resulting tool in action
so by default the app shows
edges just around the subject and image
borders with this black background
the user can adjust the slider at the
top to bring in more or less of the
image color
they can use the toggle to bring in the
remaining edges of the subject
and like in the subject and background
they can also turn off the visualization
by holding a finger down
anywhere on the screen or using the
toggle on the bottom right
so we found in the composition study
that even though we provided such a
such a toggle people barely use rarely
used it to
turn the visualization completely off
and so we added the ability to more
easily switch back and forth
by touching anywhere on the screen
as i just described we use edge
detection to capture edges of objects in
the frame
we additionally use saliency to try to
capture the context of how these
edges relate to important subjects in
the photo
by drawing attention to the subject
background relationship and the image
borders
we hope that this might encourage users
to con consider these when exploring
different ways of framing their subject
users can use this information to decide
whether or not
highlighted objects should be in the
final image
so given this tool we wanted to
understand if it
if it could help users capture more
clear and decluttered photos
and if users felt creative while using
the tool
so from our composition study we liked
how the difference in scale
resulted in a range of complexity while
composing
since we needed to run remote studies we
decided to keep that structure of having
three
tasks per condition at different scales
but having participants
choose their own subjects to take photos
of
so again participants completed six
photo tasks three at each of two
locations
of their choosing so here are a few
participant photos for each task to give
you a sense
of differences in scale for these tasks
since locations were all different here
we just counter balanced condition to
avoid biases due to learning effects
so as noted before photographers
sometimes suggest
looking at a photo in grayscale to focus
on overall contrast
so in fact many mentioned that they
currently use grayscale in their camera
even if we're taking colored photos
therefore we can compared our tool
against this method that photographers
currently employ as our baseline
we ran remote studies over zoom if the
tool would help users declutter photos
and if users felt creative while using
the tool
users experienced two different
conditions of the tool
one using a grayscale overlay
and a second highlighting edges along
the subject and image borders
for each photo we asked participants to
self-assess them
based on subject background separation
and image border flicker
we actually did not see a significant
improvement in overall quality in terms
of these principles
however participants did believe that
the tool was helpful for the task of
capturing clear and decluttered images
it also made them feel more confident in
their ability to address
the decluttering principles of subject
background separation and image border
flicker
participants described feeling like they
could take fewer photos
because they could be more confident in
each photo that they took
usually when i take photos i take a ton
at once but didn't do that here
i didn't need to because i was being so
precise
i noticed myself reconsidering the
composition more e.g
should i have these things in the edges
here you can see this participant
refines the camera angle
until the edges in the overlay look as
she wants
she's watching the hook on the top left
making sure it doesn't end up in her
shot
potentially a distractor in the
in the photo and so i'm trying to
angle my phone so that it doesn't catch
that in there um
yep
in addition to encouraging confidence we
found the tool further encourage
creativity through exploring the space
in new ways
it was really helpful with how i take
photos because normally it's just snap
and done
this one was more like can i move things
out of the background
can i move the subject to frame it to
not have a distracting background
another thing that i don't normally do
is pivot the camera and usually just
move within a flat plane
another participant said it cost me to
experiment more
i didn't see it as a rule that i needed
to minimize lines but the tool made it
easy to move around and check
by that metric how good it was
so here you can see how an unexpected
edge highlight
encourages a participant to explore
different backgrounds and compositions
so this participant notices an unwanted
edge
at the bottom of the plant from the
stovetop
so she tries out different camera angles
to remove the stove
but notice there's a dark panel in the
background which she doesn't want
she then turns the camera back towards
the white wall but notices the high
contrast object
at the top left entering her shot
an interaction that we didn't expect
that emerged from the studies
was that participants use the tool's
ability to identify subjects
to assess how someone might view their
photos
this participant observes that the tool
jumps back and forth
and it's highlighting of a subject so
she interprets this to mean that there
is no clear subject in her photo
and confirms that this is actually
consistent with her own perception
therefore she tries to find a different
way to capture this room with a more
clear subject
this participant on the other hand had a
slightly different interpretation of the
lack of a consistent subject or in this
case
no identified subject so he decided that
since the large scale task
shouldn't have a single focal subject
the lack of yellow aligned with
the skull
our edge-based overlay distilled the
concept of declutter
down to the principles of subject
background separation and image border
flicker
specifically in the context of the
current image and helped draw focus away
from the subject itself
to the surrounding regions this
visualization helped participants
quickly explore different backgrounds
and angles for capturing a subject
and ultimately feel more confident in
their photos
the difference in the way the last two
participants use the feedback
also shows that this overlay did allow
for flexible interpretation
in many cases we saw participants notice
highlighted edges
and consciously decide that they felt
like the potential noise was okay to
keep
so we've now walked you through this
photographer's process in capturing this
portrait
and presented each of our interfaces and
how they enable a novice user to
consider the decisions behind each of
these steps
with our lighting tool a novice could
choose amongst a number of lighting
styles
and reorient to achieve their desired
style
the composition tool would highlight the
centered composition
and help confirm alignment to a new
composition
finally the decluttering tool would
further emphasize the orange bag
as well as highlight the edge of the
wall on the right border of the image
we've learned a lot from our experiences
and i'm excited to continue thinking
about how these camera interfaces can
improve
for instance how might we design an
interface that combines these tools
and understands maybe when you focus on
one photography concept
versus another and especially with these
visualizations combined
how do you make sure that the interface
isn't too overwhelming
i would also be interested in
understanding how we might come up with
better quantitative metrics for
evaluating this type of work
for example could we maybe use the
motions of the camera or the user's gaze
to measure behavior change in the
photographic process
or how we might be able to measure
creative growth and learning
finally i'm excited to try to apply some
of these design goals and ideas that we
used here for photography
to other creative domains can we
similarly
similarly develop artistic vision for
things like
graphic design or fabrication
so today i presented to you our three
interfaces for capture time guidance
we talked through the motivation design
algorithmic implementation and
evaluation of each of these tools
i hope that through these projects i've
shown you
that visualizing key artistic concepts
in the camera can allow novice users to
see their image
in new ways this can help them feel more
creative and produce photos that they
like
more
i'd like to thank my advisors mentors
and committee members for all their
support throughout this journey
and for helping shape this work i'll
miss getting slack messages from james
asking if i'm back from vacation because
he heard laughter from the hallway
and pat excitedly pointing out a single
particularly beautiful pixel
or sharing his latest artistic creations
i'll miss spontaneous conversations with
manish during his frequent visits to our
office
about topics ranging from fancy food to
making viral videos
and eating through an endless supply of
duck and boughs with guh
and an endless supply of drinks at the d
lounge
thanks to ohad and his constant supply
of snark
i'll always remember to judge myself for
overly large pdf files
no and overthinking minor details but
also thank you
really thanks to jose for being an
amazingly supportive mentor with an
incredible artistic player
who is willing to hop on a call with me
at 7 pm to calm my nerves before a
weekend of user studies
and thank you scott for being here today
thank you for believing in me and for
the time and effort you've already
invested in me
i look forward to learning and growing
with you in your lab in the coming years
thank you so so much to my lab mates and
my good friends in the phd
you've been there with me every step of
the way
thank you for all of your valuable
feedback so many of you have been so
generous with your time
and spent countless hours helping me
with my work
but most of all thank you for your
friendship and for making the phd
such a special and rich experience
coming in i wasn't looking to make too
many new friends in grad school
but i i know i'll be eternally grateful
for the bonds that we've formed
well i can't talk anymore i'll treasure
the memories
of general silliness and gates from nerf
gun wars to sitting in boxes to
accumulating stuffed animals
to griffin's little surprise dances and
animal imitations
in the hallway just for me to see
a special thanks to on for keeping me
sane in the days leading up to deadlines
staying up with me many nights in a row
helping me with figures and assembling
paper submissions
you were there with me through some of
the toughest times in the phd
and i really don't know how i would have
done it without you
thank you to extreme we're welcome
welcoming me into your dance family i'm
so grateful
to have had an opportunity to learn and
grow learn from and grow with each of
you
thank you to my friends from all other
walks of life thank you
all for being here today and just
generally always being there for me
you're some of the most considerate and
thoughtful people around and i feel so
lucky to call you my friends
i was rather bummed to not be able to
defend in person but being able to have
you all here
makes it infinitely better
thank you alex for being my co-working
buddy over the past several weeks
and providing me with your very
godmotherly love and encouragement
as i pushed to finish this talk
and steve for fueling me with a mountain
of yummy surprise pastries
i think i was 90 pastry by the end of
that day
thank you chris and viv for being my
quarantine family
and for giving me something to look
forward to each week and feeding you so
much delicious food and beer
and thank you matthew my student buddy
and first collaborator at stanford
and so so much more you're the real mvp
thank you for everything you did behind
the scenes keeping me happy and fed
thank you for always making sure my
favorite foods were in the fridge
and for taking me to disneyland more
times than i can count
thanks to my family for always
supporting me and my academic as well as
creative endeavors
as a family we took a trip to new york
city on the coldest day of winter that
year
because i wanted to take photos of
benches at central park for my
photography class
and then again for my research we spent
many hours in the new jersey winter
wandering around campus
campus to take portraits with different
types of lighting
i truly would not be where i am without
you
i want to thank my advisors again i'm so
grateful for the
for the relationship that i have with my
advisors even more than research
advisors
they were my life advisors for the past
six years
from watching both of you i've learned
so much about the type of person i want
to be
i didn't know what i did to deserve your
time and trust but your unwavering
support and willingness to invest in me
has helped me become the person i am
today
i hope that someday i can have that kind
of impact on someone's career in life
and some bonus photos because i really
have
had just such amazing inventors
throughout this phd
finally i want to thank a mentor who has
a very special place in my heart
lauren passed away while i was interning
with her at adobe
after my first year
despite having only known her for a
short while
she's had an immeasurable impact on my
life
a few days into the internship i
remember calling my parents and
excitedly telling them that i found a
mentor that i was really hoping to work
with for the rest of my phd
and while she hasn't been able to
physically be there
even today sometimes when i feel like
giving up thinking about her and how
much she believed in me
gives me the strength to keep going i
wish i could have had more time with you
to share in our love of dance and
chocolate
and to celebrate our birthday together
and with that i'll end my talk thank you
all for listening and for being here
today
i'll now take any questions
thank you
and we are now all extremely self aware
of the lighting on our zoom
uh um
anyone who's a panelist feel free to
unmute yourself uh this is
i guess considered the public part of
the q a for the
for the dissertation defense uh if
you're a stanford student i'll resend
back out the link for submitting a
question
and we have a few minutes for questions
here so go ahead
they're still applauding so we'll wait
till the applause
you could read out the url too michael
we're just waiting for the claps to go
down and then they'll ask questions
okay one question we have we have
questions i can ask over the clapping um
who's asking how
visual sales how visual saliency gets
calculated in the composition study and
whether the users ever felt like that
their desired subject wasn't correctly
identified by the metric
yeah we just use the like apple has
these two built-in
um saliency algorithms one is more
attention and gaze based and one is
object-based so we use the first one
for um the composition study uh
and yeah we gave them a little bit of
training to so that they could kind of
understand how the app was working
but definitely it's not always on point
but that like having that training
allows them to kind of interpret what's
what's going on under the
under the scene um and also like
sometimes
as a result would highlight subjects
that maybe they didn't realize
were um of such like strong visual
attention
and that would also actually help them
like learn to like think to remove it or
to like
use it in their composition so some of
that serendipity was also helpful in
their exploration
yeah hi um hi this is
great um i guess i want to really
quickly talk about the composition app
um unfortunately it's the first
i've um i'm seeing it which at packs is
great um
my question is from an interaction
perspective my
initial thought would be someone would
want to keep um once they find
three lines that they like they would
want to just freeze those lines and then
do tweaks afterwards but in the app it's
constantly changing and re-optimizing
the lines
um can you comment on that decision a
little bit
yeah um we definitely thought about
doing something like that like
um saying okay i have a composition in
mind let me like select those lines
and then it'll like turn more green or
something as you're like more and more
aligned
um i think i was just excited about
getting a sense of how generating these
ideas might help you explore the space
rather than maybe refining a specific
composition
but that's definitely something that i'd
be interested in also looking at
gotcha thanks
we also had a slider at the top if you
want to slow it down so that you could
keep something on for a little longer
yeah great job jane
super interesting really well explained
the question was if someone
wanted to use all three of the tools to
take a photo would the recommended order
be the way it was presented lighting and
then
composition and then declutter and i
guess if that is
i guess how that sequence was determined
yeah um kind of
i think yeah with lighting um because
that one kind of guides you to really
reorient and so once you've reoriented
everything that's in your
you know scene is going to be really
different so decluttering and
composing before isn't necessarily the
most helpful um
composition declutter i think are a
little bit more
linked um like as you saw in the walk
like a little walk through i did
it like noticing some clutter really
changed the choice and composition there
um and i wanted to kind of illustrate
that those might kind of move back and
forth and
you're kind of touching on exactly what
i was saying uh was one of the future
work things i was
interested in it is kind of um
interesting to think about
like when one is the priority versus the
other like sometimes if you're
you really want a certain composition
you want to first compose that
and then just like move things out of
the scene but other times you know
clutter can't be moved
and so you have to kind of work around
it and compose so
yeah it's definitely also something i'm
interested in looking at more
we have a question also from an attendee
who asks uh did you investigate the
impact of the tools on the novice's
photographs as
evaluated by the experienced
photographer
yeah uh well our evaluation was um
self-assessed so they would rate kind of
i had them just rate each of their
photos based on like how well composed
how well it
um how it's decluttered et cetera the
images were
um and so then we just compared
like with and without the condition and
for
everything besides the declutter um
it did seem to help i think with
decluttr it's actually like
a more difficult and unfamiliar
kind of concept and task than the other
two
and so even when people were maybe
focused on removing something
uh near the image border sometimes it
would still creep into the photo
um and so i think that's something that
maybe like with longer
you know a longer kind of time with the
app or just more
experience with it like i do see maybe
the
quality could improve but they did see
that they felt more confident in that
and i think the question was also
interested i'm sorry i think the
question was also interested in what
would you what do you think you would
see
if you had a professional photographer
look at these and not just self-esteem
i see um yeah
i we had we did have some like
preliminary tests with like expert
evaluation we didn't see
too much of a signal there and i think
that does have to do with just like
everyone has
different um
creative intentions and style choices
and so
it is kind of difficult to have an
expert evaluate that and what we care
about more is really just like
are you happy with the photo you've
taken do you feel like you're
able to start kind of determining
what your artistic style is using these
tools and
stuff like that so i i did kind of just
prioritize
more the self um assessment part for
that reason
great and uh we have time for one more
question hi thank you for a great talk
i was wondering for the um earlier on in
the rule of thirds when you had when you
had the mask
uh you had a i think a gaussian mask to
overlay over the image and later on when
you had the border
uh highlighted in blue was there
something that determined the width of
this masking or is the or are the
results fairly
uh independent or is it effectiveness
fairly independent of
um how things are set
sorry what did he mean what what masking
and the rule of thirds
i think when you're processing the image
to get the lines uh you're overlaying
a mask with a product like a saline yeah
exactly
and also the um the border size too
yeah uh so this the rule of thirds thing
i didn't actually
show as a mask with saliency um
there is like just some sort of
underlying one that determines
you know how i'm computing scores
and i didn't determine that apple just
kind of does it in their
algorithm so i just used what they
already did and that is just based on
where they think you know gays
will be um and then
oh but the width of the gaussian mask is
that what you're asking
that i use yeah like i was wondering if
that would uh pick up or miss different
um different features in the image
depending on how large they were
yeah i think i could make the mask wider
or narrower
to just capture more i like pick
something where
it would potentially also help with
alignment but wouldn't capture like
just only along the line or something
wouldn't require like too much
so yeah i think that could change the
scores but um
just kind of picked an average thing
there and then for the
image border thing as well it was very
much like a a visual
i just thought you know that kind of
mostly captured a lot of borders and was
enough for people to really see because
if it was too narrow
it'd be hard to notice and if it were
too wide it would just be kind of
noisy